oh boy guys we've got something for you
today really heavy
can i even get this in the shot am i
even in the shot i have absolutely no
idea what's in here rumor has that
there's only 10 of these whatever is in
this box that has ever been made let's
open i have no idea i have no idea
what's in here
oh god let's do it for the
squash a lot of stuff going on back here
behind the scenes
a lot of things going on back here
cotton it says it's fragile so
i don't know
i have absolutely no idea here
none
okay
it's happening
[Music]
i don't know what this is
it says
power for all do you want to come and
see jack
but i think he might yes what is it
what is it
i bet it does charge something
okay
oh my god okay can you come here real
quick i need you to remove this box okay
take the box away go go go go go
oh my
oh i like it it's like a little
movie gift set charge
force power it's like all of their items
what is going on here wow i'm gonna be
so charged up my god mophie you guys are
incredible
oh this rose gold is sexy sexy and you
know it so this one's a usbc i've
actually haven't seen the usbc chargers
which is a good thing because i have a
feeling things are going to be getting
crazy what's over here
oh
there's more
i was excited about this but it's
oh god i'll do it for the squad i'm
unable to breathe there's one thing that
really gets me going is it some movie
charging power bricks
power station
my body is ready when anybody says
justine can i charge my phone
my god what's this one
look at all these
look at all of them
like i don't want to cry
but i feel like i might cry i don't know
why this is like so freaking awesome
when they said power for all it's
actually power for all it shows you
everything
that they have my pokemon hunting has
just been
taken to a whole new level
oh my gosh look nine of ten there's
there actually is only ten of these in
the whole world i'm saving this forever
i will take this to my grave i wonder if
i could fit this in there it's in my
will
please bury me with this mophie power
for all chest it's kind of morbid all
right let's go through these power
station xxl power station xl power
station for usb c mobi power station
just
power station movie power station mini
movie power station plus with built-in
i don't think he'll stand up
mostly power station plus xl
multi-power plus
in pink
and this one is the charge for station
it wirelessly will charge if you have
one of the mophie charging cases already
which i'm not actually sure if this will
potentially work if the iphone 7 has
wireless charging or not because if
that's the case this is the future
holy moly well thank you mophie so much
because you guys are by far i have been
your biggest fan for as long as i can
even remember i think from like the
first mophie case that they ever had for
like the original iphone oh my goodness
you know what i need to do i need to set
up like a mophie
power station
charging station and you get a really
nice
power strip and a bunch of usb
bricks
and charge these babies well guys i will
see you later i'll put uh some links in
the description if you want to get any
more information about these this is not
sponsored but they did send me this and
i am beside myself
thanks for watching i'll see you guys in
the next tech tuesday
god they even smell good
maybe tonight
[Music]